[Musique]
et avant d'accueillir Johanna souri je
vous propose juste de partir pour les
sales de Saint-Quentin en Eveline les
salles de cinéma vos sorties ciné
qu'avez-vous pensé des nouveaux films à
l'affiche au micro d'éodie moine j'ai
été voir le monde de les mondes de Ralph
et ben j'ai bien aimé parce que c'était
marrant il y avait plein de plein de
jeux et tout ça on voyait plein de
bonbons dans des mondes et tout ça
c'était marrant j'ai pensé que c'était
bien par tu voir Cogan et moi j'ai
trouvéis ça pas mal du tout c'est ouais
c'est une bonne critique de comment dire
du du monde he parce que ça ça ça ça
tape bien dessus quoi ouais est pas mal
du tout j'ai bien aimé euh un petit peu
long à partir euh après euh ça sur la
fin ça bouge un petit peu mais disons
que c'est un peu c'est un peu à la
Tarantino les dialogues sont un peu
longs
c'est un peu fatiguant on va dire ah ben
j'ai pensé que c'était très très très
mauvais et que j'ai failli partir
plusieurs fois c'est des une suite de
une suite de gag quelques-uns font rire
d'autres font pas rire du tout voilà
c'est
tout la chronique culture de ce mercredi
Johann rebonsoir rebonsoir Wilfried et
bonsoir à papy qui nous a rejoint sur le
plateau de cette suiteons à T al papy on
vous connais surtout comme directeur
artistique de la compagnie de théâtre
Déclic Théâtre attrape mais là ce soir
vous venez nous parler d'une pièce une
comédie que vous alleit interpréter à
coignère les pas tout seul ah oui bah on
sait mais quand même vous avez un rô
important dans cette pièce alors il
s'agit du voyage de Monsieur Pichon qui
sera joué les 13 14 et 18 décembre au
Théâtre Alphonse d'udet et vous allez à
coagère et vous allez jouer le rôle
principal je joue le rôle de Monsieur
Pichon mais quand quand on voit la pièce
on s'aperçoit que c'est c'est c'est
assez bien distribué en fait elle c'est
équilibré et c'est le rôle titre mais
pas forcément le rôle principal parce
que les je dirais que les rôles
principaux sont les les deux prétendants
dans l'intrigue il y a deux prétendants
à ma fille alors racontez-nous
l'histoire l'hoire monsieur pierichon
monsieur pierrichon un petit commerçant
de de Paris vient de vendre son affaire
et a décidé d'emmener sa famille sa
femme et sa fille en voyage pour faire
découvrir à sa fille le le grand
spectacle de la nature et sympathique
fort sympathique jovial décontracté il
part donc et sauf que vient s'inviter au
voyage deux prétendants euh que la fille
à courti enfin qui s'est fait qui
courtisait cette jeune femme et donc qui
vont je veux dire être en compétition
pour essayer d'avoir les euh les les les
comment dire le les faveurs du père les
faveurs du père mais chacun va avoir une
technique un peu différente une approche
différente et c'est là que fille dans
tout ça alors est-ce qu'elle a son mot à
dire mais vous savez nous sommes au 19e
siècle la fille dans tout ça ne dit rien
et un peu et un peu le c'est surtout un
vraiment vraiment on s'aperçoit que
c'était une écriture très très macho
quand même de l'époque euh et
effectivement tout va se jouer entre ces
deux garçons et le père euh et je ne
diraiis pas qui gagne à la fin donc euh
justement c'est un classique ça veut
dire que c'est difficile à jouer ou que
vous vous interdisez certaines enfin il
faut se remettre dans le contexte de
l'époque pour le jouer ou alors là euh
là il y a un partiprix de du mur en
scène qui effectivement on a repris il y
a des des panneaux peints qui sont
repris des années 30 donc il y a un
parti prix d'être à la fois de le jouer
un peu comme à l'époque mais d'être
aussi dans une version un peu moderne en
plus il y a deux musiciens sur le
plateau deux pianistes superbes qui
interprètent du Poulin qui était pas qui
est une musique pas pas d'époque aussi
mais donc voilà il y a toute une
ambiance un rythme puis François
Guillaum le metteur en scène et et un
coup de scalpel particulièrement bien
précis et a réussi à redonner un un
rythme très soutenu à cette à cette
comédie vous avez fait une adaptation en
fait tout à fait c'est une adaptation et
il y a plein il y a plein de petites
lourdeurs de l'époque il y avait pas la
télévision je suis désolé TF 78 n'était
pas encore là pas encore mais depuis
effectivement vous avez tellement
éclipsé tout le monde Téf 78 je fais de
la pub euh que que non voilà donc là on
a un spectacle vivant qui qui tient
vraiment et puis pour moi c'est un petit
défi de de de
venir titiller classique just voilà et
puis vous disez vous n'étiez pas seul
sur scène il y a François Guillon qui
est le metteur en scène al voilà et on
est CIN comédien donc qui qui qui
prenont à tour à tour les différents
personnages de cette de cette pièce
comment c'est fait la rencontre avec eux
vous les connaissiez avant j'imagine que
vous connaissiez François guillaon alors
François Guillaum mène un travail
intéressant c'est un des rare dans les
toutes les salles qu'il y a dans le coin
à être aussi metteur en scène à avoir
vraiment une dimension artistique ce qui
n'est pas le cas de tous les directeurs
des salles ici qui sont des
administrateurs ou des gens de
communication mais qui sont pas
forcément des des artistes il faut
préciser que c'est le directeur du
théâtre thâre al qui effectivement tous
les
ans met en scène une une une pièce dans
son théâtre et donc fait appel à des
comédiens professionnels et c'est pas la
première fois qu'il fait appel à nous
des clics théâtre Arnaud de sa mère est
passé là-bas on a tous été joué une fois
ou deux où François n nous fait le
plaisir de de nous caster on va dire
pour pour ça donc j'ai joué le bourjo
gentillum kNOK et voilà ou donc en fait
le classique c'est une habitude
maintenant facile non c'est qui
compliqué pour moi parce que il y a un
rapport j'ai un rapport au texte assez
compliqué moi qui viens de l'impro euh
donc là j'ai un quand même assez
conséquent et voilà donc toute
l'angoisse c'est le texte et justement
vous prenez des libertés avec le texte
mais oui mal malheureusement WIF je
prends quelques liberté et tu me connais
donc je j'ai tendance à à vouloir en
faire un peu trop mais euh ce qui est
bien aussi a que ce type de texte et que
ça permet à mon grand ma grande capacité
à être Cabo à à pouvoir se se se faire
aussi ça veut dire un débrief difficile
avec le metteur en scène mais pas du
tout parce qu'il me connaît il me
pratique depuis longtemps il le savait
il le savait après il regrette des fois
un peu en disant
leex reviens au texte s'il te plaît mais
je m'y accroche et euh il y a pas de
souffleur non il y a malheureusement
pour moi je mais il y a pas de souffleur
donc donc mais le public ne s'en
aperçoit pas je rattrape la chose et et
non mais on fait ça avec Briot et
franchement ce qui est intéressant c'est
la démarche de François d'ailleurs qui a
qui a fait un gros travail sur coignère
de un public sa sal est toujours pleine
donc là on voit vraiment qu'il y a un
espace pour l'espace pour le spectacle
vivant TVF 78 qui nous fait de la pub
donc c'est bien mais il y a un espace
pour le pour le spectacle vivant encore
le texte papi le texte oui oui oui voilà
encore une fois oui tout à fait alors on
parle de la télévision justement on va
rester dans la téléréalité voil bah oui
avec la starac qui revient un autre type
de culture oui mais quand même ça passe
à la télé alors la société de production
en desmol a choisi de s'installer à
Châteaufort tout près de chez nous dans
le domaine de la jeunesse et nous avons
rencontré la propriétaire qui compte
déjà ouvrir le château public après s
l'émission un château de 1000 m Carr
logé en Vallée de Chevreuse dans un
domaine de 23 hactares un tableau qui
fait rêver un lieu parfait pour
accueillir aux portes de Paris les
décors d'une émission de télééalité il
s'agit de la Star Academy qui a choisi
le château de la jeuneste pour son grand
retour mais à qui appartient cette
demeure datant de 1850 depuis l'année
dernière Isabelle pazic en est
l'heureuse propriétaire je cherchais une
écurie à reprendre dans la région et
j'ai une amie qui avait son chev
donc dans dans ces écuries et qui
m'avait fait découvrir le domaine il y a
au moins 4 5 ans on s'est dit qu'il y
avait vraiment un beau projet à faire
donc au niveau équitation et aussi au
niveau avec tout le bâti qu'il y avait
quelque chose à faire il y a donc les
écuries il y a donc le château il y a
donc la tour
et un pavillon de dessin qui est une une
petite maison qui est un petit peu sur
le haut ah bah c'est un petit peu irréel
en fin de compte parce que on arrive du
plateau de la clé on peut arriver d'une
zone qui est quand même hyper urbanisée
on descend dans cette vallée et puis on
arrive dans ce cette verdure oui oui
forcément il y a forcément un coup de
cœur Isabelle décide de mettre en
location le château pour détournages
après quelques clichés de mode c'est
autour d'enémol d'investir les lieux
pour plusieurs mois fin février les
équipes de production démontront les
décors pour rendre le château fin mars
isabelle pazic a déjà quelques projets
comme l'ouverture du site au public pour
les journées du PAT
on va je dirais commémorer les c'est les
100 ans du premier s en parachute qui
s'est fait au-dessus du domaine de la
jeunesse pour organiser l'événement
Pascal Bouchin un habitant de
Châteaufort passionné par l'histoire de
son village il y a plusieurs châteaux à
Châteaufort il y a le château du Gavois
il y avait le château d'or il y a le
château de la Geneste donc c'est vrai
qu'il y avait plusieurs propriétés issu
des anciens fiefs en 1913 le site
s'inscrit dans l'histoire grâce à cé
Péou un jeune aviateur travaillant à Buc
pour Louis Blerot lors d'un test réalisé
au-dessus du domaine de la jeuneste le
pilote audacieux abandonne son avion en
plein vol et réussit à sauver sa vie en
sautant en parachute le parachute s'est
ouvert en plein vol et a arracher son le
pilote de son avion et
l'avion s'est retrouvé seul à 250 m
d'altitude au lieu de tomber bêtement il
est remonté à la verticale il a décroché
sur la queue il est remonté une seconde
fois un petit peu comme un avion en
papier
l'avion aurait accompli un looping et
c'est ainsi qu''est né la voltige
aérienne et oui à Châteaufort de la
chanson à l'aviation il n'y a qu'un
pas la chronique culture donc ce soir
dans le 78 sur TV fil avec alin dego
papi qu'on connaît bien pour dé clic
théâtre même si on parlait d'une pièce
tout à l'heure qui qui n'a rien à voir
mais là on parlait de la star academmy
tout à fait et ce qui pourrait aussi ne
rien avoir à voir mais mais pour autant
vous auriez pu être professeur à la Star
Academy mais j'aurais pu Wilfried
j'aurais pu parce que effectivement il y
a quelques années ils m'ont contacté
voyez-vous comme quoi le travail qu'on
fait sur sur Saint-Quentin porte ses
fruits donc ils étaient intéressés
effectivement peut-être par mettre
quelque chose autour du travail autour
de l'improvisation théâtrale et euh
alors pourquoi ça ne s pas fait bah ça
ne s'est pas fait parce que je crois que
j'ai été j'ai mis des conditions à ma
venue parce que voilà l'image de la star
academie pour moi c'était bon c'est
quand même assez loin de mon travail sur
sur Saint-Quentin et j'aurais dit bah
écoutez c'est très bien et puis
justement les jeunes de la starac
pourrai rencontrer les jeunes de 5qu1
qui viendrai on fera un match avec eux
et là ils sont dit mais ce gars-là faut
pas qu'on le laisse rentrer parce qu'il
va il va nous ramener trappe
Saint-Quentin voisin tout ça et donc il
va mettre trop d'ambiance oui je pense
que j'étais ils ont eu un peu peur alors
ils sont dit bah écoutez on va vous
rappeler et ils ne m'ont pas rappelé
mais je vois qu'ils viennent jusqu'à il
rapoche
il piier la téléréalité vous connaissez
bien puis que vous avez coaché Laurent
Renac dans Mon incroyable fiancé oui
vous êtes bien renseigné Jan sououdri je
vois effectivement effectivement j'ai
travaillé pour la téléréalité avec avec
Laurent sur mon incroyable fiancé sur le
premier euh qu'est-ce que vous retenez
de cette expérience écoutez c'est c'est
très bizarre parce que à la fois ça pose
un problème de conscience sur le côté
voyurisme qui peut y avoir là-dessus sur
le travail d'un autre côté moi j'étais
au service de Laurent parce que pour moi
c'était formidable pour lui d'être
d'être un casting permanent je pense
qu'il a bien tiré son épingle du jeu et
que effectivement notre du duo a bien
fonctionné maintenant je reste toujours
c'est
sur effectivement le le le fond de de de
ce type de de de
programme maintenant il faut constater
aussi que ça fait il y a plein de jeunes
qui qui du coup vont vont essayer de de
de de passer des aller dans des cours
travailler leur champ travailler leur
voix travailler le Tex font pour les
bonnes raisons aussi c'est la question
qu'on peut se poser il y avait des
radios crochet dans les années 30 il y
avait donc voilà est-ce que c'est est-ce
qu'il y a aussi on est dans la
continuité de ça il y a a toujours eu
par les médias un effet de même ce qu'on
voit sur Antenne 2 ou ailleurs là sa
mère s'il avait pas s'il était pas passé
à pas class parce que j'y ai pensé j'ai
pasé ça me fait plaisir au moin d'êre
senu va quand même pas faire je vois ça
je vois ça donc France Télévision pour
pas les citer donc voilà je je pense que
c'est aussi dans la tradition française
de ces radio crochets qu'il y avait à la
Radi radio ensuite ce qu'il y a eu sur
les les premiers plateaux télé où il y
avait aussi cette forme là sur France 2
effectivement on demande on en demande
qu'à en rire a permis à des jeunes qui
n'étaient pas connus de se faire
connaître donc c'est il y a quand même
des talents qui sortent de là il serait
peut-être passer autre part on les
aurait connu aussi mais là ça va plus
vite il' y a un effet accélérateur de la
télé voyez moi je je fais un TVF 78 et
du coup je suis connu comme le loup
blanc sur Saint-Quentin donc CIT j'ai
commencé presque là j'ai vu Wilfried je
lui donn le biberon un truc incroyable
ça c'est pas sympa alors vous êes
vraiment vous touchez à tout un théâtre
impr télévision il y a quelque chose que
vous préférez dans ces trois disciplines
je crois que vraiment je reste je reste
vraiment le théâtre là d'aller jouer
d'être sur ce plateau à
coignère alfon la semaine prochaine avec
toute l'angoisse de dire faut pas que je
me plante parce que c'est du spectacle
vivant et j'aurais pas le droit un
deuxième enfin j'ai le droit à TR à TR
TR comment direou 13 14 et 18 13 et 14
et 18 et puis et puis voilà ce momentlà
reste un moment
[Musique]
particulier parce que de partager avec
le public sur le sur le moment qui est
qui est fort et voilà et donc dans la
tradition de déclic parce que après je
reprends l'isistrata avec des clic
théâes pour le 26 le 26 janvier à morpa
donc encore un autre rôle encore un
autre classique comme quoi vous voyez
fait Fred j'arrête pas de faire des
classiques alors justement Papion on
parlait de de Déclic Théâtre ça y est la
saison reprend ce weekend les premers
matchs auront lieu ce samedi le 8
décembre à l'école de musique et de
danse de trappe alors il y a trois
matchs à 14h30 ce sont les benjamins les
plus petits à partir de 8 ans à 16h les
cadets un petit peu plus grand et puis à
20h les juniors donc jusqu'à de 15 à 19
ans c'est quand même grand à 19 ans non
c'est pas grand on est encore tout petit
maintenant on reste on reste très
longtemps à la maison jusqu'à 30 ans
donc non ça ça reste petit maintenant
donc un un seul une seule adresse
internet pour avoir des renseignements
c'est
www.declictheatre.net et donc d'autres
dates dans l'agenda après allez-y c'est
parti on vaêtre remercier PAP aussi
c'est ça remerciez- mooi merci Salut
wifri en même temps vous restez encore
avec nous en plateau le temps d'écouter
les sorties ce qu'on peut faire ce
weekend sur Saint-Quentin alors on va
peut-être passer du côté de maniléamo à
la Maison de l'environnement pour
découvrir la place des mythos ça c'est
quelque chose qui vous plairait papi
c'est une pièce qui a été écrite par des
jeunes qui viennent de risoringis et
donc ils sont programmés dans le cadre
des Pulsations Urbaines sur
Saint-Quentin en ieline c'est à 20h30 on
va passer ensuite à la ferme du Mousseau
que vous connaissez bien il vous propose
un weekend à Québec c'est la compagnie
ici Londres euh oui c'est ça ici Londes
qui s'installe à hencour donc pour trois
représentations de samedi et une
dimanche autour de d'auteur québécois et
puis la compagnie les gens qui tombent
interprèteront aussi en diptique sortir
de sa mère ça c'est vendredi soir et la
chair des tristes CUS samedi soir donc
ça c'est au théâtre herridis à plaisir
et ensuite à la maison de Coville et
bien vous pourrez découvrir la bienénale
des peintres vissinois jusqu'au dimanche
donc c'est le 9 et vous verrez la maison
de Coville qui a été entièrement rénovée
voilà flamb pour cette agenda et puis
une information puisqu'on parlait tout à
l'heure de 50 ans neline de trappe un
mot sur au Marcille au Marcille qui va
revenir à 50 ans neline le temps d'une
avant-première de l'autre côté du périf
c'est son nouveau film le 11 décembre à
21h il sera à l'UGC de Montini le
Bretonneux nous aurons l'occasion d'en
reparler et puis il y a des places à
gagner sur notre site Internet et vient
les réseaux sociaux également si vous
voulez participer être présent lors de
cette avant-première un échange avec le
public est prévu au marc il est pas
passé par des C théâre même s'il vient
de trappe et non il est pas passé ce qu'
me dis c'est ce que me disait Omar il me
dit mais moi j'avais trop peur papi
j'avais trop peur d'aller un patimard
mais il nous a toujours soutenu toujours
été là tout au long de de de du
développement de la compagnie de la
radio donc non Omar c'est un vrai copain
aussi puis les spit rapist parce que et
non seulement il mais il venait voir
tous les matchs d'un pro il me dis je
venis voir mais ça me faisait vraiment
trop peur aujourd'hui je pense qu'il a
un peu moins peur on va on va dire
d'aller se montrer sur les écrans
peut-être prochainement dans la patin
noire alors voilà peut-être
prochainement dans la pati dans les
tuyaux ah voilà voilà pour le scoop pour
finir cette séquence culture merci
Johanna merci papi aussi d'être venue
sur ce plateau il nous reste une dizaine
de minutes à passer ensemble elles
seront consacrées à la politique lump la
crise àump vue par les jeunes militants